Morning?
My night gave way to the morning, though
the new day brought no relief.
The rain fell steadily, its monotonous tapping against
the windowpane filling the room with a sense
of dreariness.
Outside the world was shrouded in grey, and
inside the dim light seemed to make the
walls press in closer.
My head throbbed, and a faint dizziness clouded
my thoughts.
A dull fever seemed to creep through my
limbs, draining what little strength I had left.
"'Sir, there's a letter for you,' Matrona said
gently, bending toward me.
"'The postman just delivered it.' "'A letter?' I
exclaimed, the words escaping my lips before I
could process them.
"'From whom?' I asked, sitting up sharply in
my chair.
"'I don't know, sir,' she replied calmly.
"'You should check.
It might say who it's from.' My hands
trembled as I took the letter.
I stared at the envelope for a moment,
recognizing the handwriting.
My heart leapt, then sank under the weight
of anticipation.
It was from her.
It was from Nastenka.
Breaking the seal with unsteady fingers, I unfolded
the letter.
For a moment the words swam before my
eyes, and then I began to read.
"'Oh, forgive me.
Please, forgive me.
I am begging you on my knees to
forgive me.
I've deceived you, and I've deceived myself.
Everything was a dream, an illusion.
My heart aches for you today.
Please forgive me.
Don't blame me, because I haven't changed how
I feel about you.
I told you I would love you, and
I still do.
I love you now more than I ever
did.
Oh, if only I could love you both
at once!
If only you were him!' "'Oh, if only
he were you,' echoed through my mind as
I read.
Her words stirred memories of what she had
said before, cutting deeper into my heart.
"'God knows what I would do for you
now.
I know you're sad and heartbroken, and I
know I've hurt you.
But you also know that when someone truly
loves, they forgive quickly.
And you love me, don't you?
Thank you, thank you for that love.
It will stay with me forever, like a
sweet dream that lingers even after waking.
I will always remember the moment you opened
your heart to me so selflessly, like a
brother, and took my broken heart into your
care with such tenderness and kindness.
"'If you forgive me, I will carry the
memory of your love in my heart forever,
like an unshakable gratitude etched into my soul.
I will honor that memory.
I will stay true to it.
I won't betray it, nor will I betray
my heart.
It remains as constant as ever.
It found its way back to him so
easily, so quickly, because it always belonged to
him."
I paused, the letter trembling in my hands,
and I swallowed hard before continuing.
The words blurred, but I pressed on.
"'We'll meet again.
You'll come to us.
You won't leave us.
You'll always be my friend, my brother.
And when you see me, you'll give me
your hand, won't you?
Please say you will.
Tell me you've forgiven me.
Tell me you still love me, just as
you did before.
Oh, don't stop loving me.
Please don't abandon me, because I love you
so much in this moment.
I want to be worthy of your love,
and I promise I'll work to deserve it.
My dear, next week I'm marrying him.
He has come back to me, still in
love, still thinking of me.
You won't be angry that I'm writing to
you about him, will you?
But I want to see you again, with
him.
I know you'll like him.
Please say you will.
Forgive me, remember me, and love me always.
Your, Nastenka."
I read the letter again and again, unable
to stop myself.
Each word felt like a wave crashing over
me, and tears filled my eyes until they
overflowed.
Finally, the letter slipped from my hands, and
I covered my face, overwhelmed by emotion.
"'Dearie, dearie,' Matrona called out from the doorway.
"'What is it, Matrona?' I asked, my voice
breaking slightly.
"'I've taken down all the cobwebs from the
ceiling.
You could have a wedding here, or even
throw a party if you wanted,' she said
cheerfully.
I turned to look at Matrona.
She was still sturdy and strong for her
age, a lively woman who carried herself with
youthful energy, yet in that moment I suddenly
saw her differently.
In my mind she aged before my eyes,
her gaze dull, her face deeply lined, her
figure stooped and frail.
I couldn't explain why, but that vision seemed
to fill the entire room.
I imagined my surroundings mirroring her decay.
The walls appeared to lose their colour, the
floors seemed worn and faded, and the cobwebs
she had proudly removed seemed to grow back
thicker and heavier than before.
I couldn't shake the feeling that the room
itself was growing old with her, taking on
the weight of years.
When I glanced out the window, even the
house across the street seemed affected by time.
Its once bright façade now looked dim and
weathered.
The stucco on the grand columns was crumbling
and flaking off, the cornices showed dark cracks,
and the once vivid yellow walls had turned
patchy and dull.
Perhaps it was the sun.
It had broken briefly through the clouds, casting
a golden light, only to retreat again behind
the veil of rain, leaving everything looking grey
and lifeless once more.
Or perhaps it was my own imagination, painting
my future in bleak, sombre tones.
I saw myself in that room fifteen years
from now, just as lonely, just as unchanged.
The same Matrona would still be there, no
wiser, no more lively than she was to
-day.
But to think I could ever resent you,
Nastenka.
How could I?
That I could darken your happiness with bitterness,
or weigh down your heart with guilt.
That I could speak words of blame to
disturb your peace, or spoil the joy you
feel as you walk to the altar with
him.
Never, never.
I could never be so cruel.
Instead I wish for you the clearest skies,
for your laughter to remain bright and your
smiles unclouded.
May you never feel regret, may your joy
remain untouchable, and may you be blessed for
giving even one moment of pure happiness to
someone who will always be grateful.
A single moment of happiness, a brief spark
of light in a dark life.
Isn't that enough?
Isn't that worth an entire lifetime?